-Right now, guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Well, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week, in honor of
Valentine's Day,
I sent out the #WhyImSingle.
And I asked you guys to tweet
out a funny reason
why you think you're single.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.
So thank you very much.
Now I'd like to share
some of my favorite
#WhyImSingle tweets
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one is
from @djtheoldman. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Why not get gloves?
-I don't know, man.
Or just put your hands under...
-Under the blanket.
-...the blanket.
-Get some pocket warmers.
-No, he thinks
that's why he's single.
This one's from @etes97.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'd like the sal-mon, please.
-Bolth of them.
-Bolth.
This one's from @dun-- oh --
@DunLahfAtMae
-Don't laugh at me.
[ Laughter ]
Don't laugh at me.
-Don't laugh at me.
[ Laughs ]
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There's no shame in that.
-No shame.
-There is no shame in that.
That is fantastic.
I do the same thing. Why not?
This one is from @MarkWithAnM.
-Mmm.
-That's funny, too.
These are funny people.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @kyledice23.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Bunny goes around the tree.
-This one's from @greenantaylor.
She says...
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
-Hey! Get together.
-Hey, there, hold on.
There's someone else we can set
you up with.
[ Laughter ]
@DunLahfAtMae.
-Get together, man.
-You guys should connect.
We made a connection.
[ Laughs ] Fat, single,
ready for a Pringle.
I love that jam.
This one's from @whitedaisies07.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's pretty much
a deal breaker.
-That's a deal --
Yeah, that's --
-"You can date me if you don't
breathe, though."
-Yeah. "How long can you hold
your breath?"
[ Laughter ]
You can only hang out
underwater.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @septicor.
-Ooh!
Septicor, activate!
-Sounds like a monster truck.
Sunday, Sunday, Sunday!
-Septicor!
-It's crazy!
[ Laughter ]
-@Septicor, he says...
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Septicor.
-This last one's
from @buddychampagne. He says...
-Yeah!
-There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.